voir notre performance va être assurée
par guillaume meurice il est au théâtre
populaire
tous les lundis à 21h30 pour son
spectacle tout le monde y passe
one man show hyundai se bonsoir à la
voix rauque tout de noir vêtus sont
voilà qui lui aura rien de bonbons soir
bon alors je ne dis rien sur votre tenue
en découvrir un peu pourquoi elle est là
parce qu'il ya toute une galerie de
personnages alors théâtre populaire vous
avez une culture classique en fait vous
avez fait pour florange et dire comme
tout le monde
enfin vous l'avez vous voulez fait très
longtemps 4 2 mais là j'ai été assistant
en fait d'une d'une prof la dernière
année en fait le con florent permettait
ça à l'époque je crois encore maintenant
d'ailleurs on fait sociaux de
l'assistant du président gilles
quatrième année ça permettait de monter
un spectacle aussi d'avoir les lots
alors vous avez joué du molière du
feydeau des classiques ouais ouais ouais
molière feydeau j'ai fait un peu de
théâtre de rue aussi et après alors le
one man show c'est dur parce qu'il faut
dire que ce spectacle tout le monde
il passe tourne depuis 2007 c'est ça
ouais alors après avec des aménagements
avec des changements de ce qui est pas
mal de sujets d'actualité donc les
personnages qui sont partis avec
d'autres qui sont arrivés voilà alors il
ya beaucoup de déguisements et mais ça
ouais je vous en faisant ce weed surtout
dans la petite salle beaucoup de
costumes
ouais moi j'aime bien en fait je savais
pas en fait quand j'ai commencé moins de
mal je ne savais pas que c'était plus à
la mode au fait
donc j'ai découvert ça envoie du beurre
mais c'est hyper ringard pour permettre
des costumes j'ai du bon vin ça me fait
marrer
loris est ringard voilà alors attention
donc à la norme s'est fait marrer puis
ouais c'est vrai que ça en fait c'est un
effet comique aussi le costume donc ça
qui rigole comme cette méga lourd plus
les dieux avec un fils un petit peu
rebelle mais c'est ça dieu ça me permet
aussi d'avoir de prendre de la hauteur
si je disais moi en tant que guillaume
meurice toutes les choses que je dis
dans les sketches de dieu et j'ose dire
est pas c'est vachement moralisateur nos
classes je mets un costume une fosse
barrois et un peignoir jeudi qui vient
de se réveiller
diot découvre le monde et il peut donner
son avis c'est quand même un peu le
bordel là depuis 2010 on le sait à
n'importe quoi ils auraient mieux fait
pas les deux pas et se coucher le
septième jeu aurait carrément alors là
on vous voit habillée en noir pour nous
donner un extrait de votre spectacle
vous c'est que vous allez monter soit là
et je vais vous remettre à l'us dax et
d'accessoires un accessoire un
accessoire un peu effrayant
on se tient tranquille
[Applaudissements]
guillaume meurice ap d'applaudissements
podium aurait cependant sur terre
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
un bon commandant soir
ah ça va il est bien dommage
je cherche quelqu'un qui est sur ma
liste et que je soupçonne de se cacher
parmi vous ouais c'est bien dénoncer
vous voulez en france d'ailleurs
problème pour y aller dépêchez-vous j'ai
une réunion ou un geste après par contre
1 1 c'est ben laden c'est poutine c'est
kadhafi
je m'emmerdais mokhtar ben faut que
michel ma cliente est là alors qu'est ce
que je suis et où à part de rochers
désolé là c'est le stress qui fait ça je
m'excuse je devrais pas l'avoir en plus
je n'aurais pas fait le monopole mois
mais on remet ça garantit pas le boulot
votation un mois boulot je vous parle
vrai boulot hein je vous parle pas de la
petite vieille qui va mourir dans sa
maison de retraite
moi je vous parle pas du gamin qui boit
de l'eau de javel à banon me baudoux par
le génocide famines épidémies guerres
civiles du coders à bombay heureusement
pour sage et l'afrique
ouais l'afrique c'est le seul endroit du
monde où je peux bosser tranquille
jamais en vernis là bas tout le monde
s'en fout bon si les petites
organisations humanitaires qui viennent
me titille un petit peu de temps en
temps mais bon c'est le jeu aussi là je
vais croiser sur la route avec leur
petite famille au pardon aussi émouvant
quand même je trouve ça va vous sinon ça
se passe bien
elle est français c'est un petit peu
calme en ce moment chez vous à leur
colère c'est vrai nom mais je bosse
beaucoup avec vous les français
notamment l'hiver ouais au niveau des
sdf
bah oui ça c'est une promesse d autres
présidents ça il a dit plus de sdf en
france d'ici deux ans allez et picasa
non mais je vais pas vous le cacher plus
longtemps
le plus gros de mon chiffre d'affaires
ça reste quand même l'international
c'est vrai que les états unis ils ont 30
ans d'avancé avec abba là bas ils m'ont
carrément fait construire un couloir
je te jure qu'il porte pour nous rendre
les armes
luedecke attendre des années avant de
pouvoir me rencontrer un adversaire que
vous soyez un petit peu compte pas en
profiter ce soir a finalement rats non
les personnes
ah bon bah j'ai le temps j'attends moi
tiens moi ça tient elle va pas le
laisser
sabo est une fausse et une vraie
[Applaudissements]
spectacle d'humour je suis obligé de
rajouter quand même des volailles
excusez moi j'aime faire juste une
petite pause je suis désolé il ya des
fumeurs parmi vous pas ce soir allez la
plainte est un cadeau c'est pour toi
c'est la bataille commence commence
alors
[Musique]
j'en ai plein c'est mon sponsor nicotine
8 mg bouderont débiner g dès lors c'est
au début j'y croyais pas du tout - pour
les mets qui me ramenait sa jeudi à
temps jean-luc voudront 10 mg les jours
ils vont s'apercevoir que tu veux leur
faire fumer la route
non mais rigole pas sa charte en cela un
tabac et rhodia
voilà un spectacle d'humour elle viendra
lui et non le problème qu'on a avec ce
genre de truc c'est les délais
parce qu'on peut plus se permettre
maintenant de laisser traîner les
cancers des chimio avec des traitements
lourds pendant des années tu vois faut
être humain
non mais je me dis n ya pas génocide
tous les jours vous êtes marrants un
huissier du boulanger l'eau si vous les
trouvez les justifications à chaque fois
à ses parents quand on réfléchit bien à
vous tous vous pousse à vous aider à
vous acheter des disques de céline dion
ou alors ça parle d'amour abadie amour
toujours à hélène ségara c'est pareil
toi alors ils étaient 40 amour toujours
à montcuq sais qui tu as l'air derrière
un [ __ ] journée pour remplir les
titres et les quotas métabolique est la
goutte à goutte
qu'est ce que c'est que ça excusez moi
je suis désolé pardon hein oui alors
ouais non tu me dérange pas non non je
suis avec des futurs clients là ouais
non mais j'ai pas le temps ce moment
n'ont jamais accepté le poste de drh à
france télécom
ouais on fait un petit plan social alors
et ses portes à la whey attend qu'il
part qu'il fasse un double appel qui toi
bah ouais ouais johnny j'arrive je suis
à la bourre c'est pour pour lutter
contre la surpopulation carcérale
bah écoute 156,6 de l'année dernière je
peux pour faire mieux c'est marrant toi
aussi
non faut que tu arrêtes de m'appeler
rachida nom n'était plus ministre a
laissé aller voilà je t'embrasse très
basse à la petite en passant à la petite
zohra
j'espère qu'elle va réussir ses examens
adn aux jeux rigolos et susceptible bon
bah je obligé d'y retourner
je vous laisse on se voit bientôt toute
façon ben voilà c'est du meurice vous
retrouverez
au théâtre populaire la zune 21h30 pour
son spectacle tout le monde y passe et
voit la fin du spectacle
n'oubliez pas de passer au chapeau pour
guillaume meurice you maurice encore
bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]